hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
kochwelt heute gibt es mal wieder ein
türkisches rezept ich werde heute machen
ich habe schon mal vor langer zeit eine
abgemachte die waren allerdings gefüllt
und heute möchte ich euch die aktuelle
version zeigen dies sollte bei
türkischen bäckereien gibt das sind
nämlich so schöne große teiglinge diesen
super luftig super locker und in der
türkei kann man die zum beispiel auch
als sandwich kaufen als da kann man
schön belegen zeige ich euch dann auch
am ende wie ich sie belege und ich hab
da einfach so richtig lust drauf die
gibt's auch im flugzeug aufzukaufen
von cicero oder ebenso in der stadt ich
glaube aber auch beim türkischen bäcker
hier in deutschland und ich zeige ich es
einfach mal die zutaten bisschen
normaler hefeteig
ich brauche einen würfel hefe der war
bei mir tief gefroren deswegen sieht so
aus 1 esslöffel zucker 2 weiß ein
teelöffel salz ein glas war mädels haben
wir hier ein glas warmes wasser ein glas
öl und die haben alle 250 milliliter
dann ein kilo mehl und zum bestreichen
später zwei eigelb zwei esslöffel zucker
und etwas schwarzkümmel zeige ich es
später dazu
was ist genau dann kribbelt zuerst gebe
ich jetzt die hefe in die schüssel rein
und hefe habe ich immer auf die
tiefgefroren aber auch auf frische hefe
nur hat es dem morath vergesst die
frische hefe mitzunehmen
macht aber nichts denn das wasser ist
schön warm und damit geht es dann
einfach schön kann auch schön aufteilen
da das wasser und den zucker mit rein
und dann vermischt es so miteinander
wenn sich die hefe dann aufgelöst hat
gebe ich auch gleich mit meter zu dann
auch das eiweiß und ich finde sei total
praktisch wenn man weiß im teig hat und
das eigelb von oben rein dann hat man
eben nix im überfluss dann gebe ich etwa
die hälfte des mehls mal mit dazu das
mittelmeer ist schlimm und das ist
einfach mal gut durchkneten und dann
gebe ich gleich salz und noch eine halbe
tasse und rein
ich glaube für eine tasse praktischen
habe ich mag es hier gleich mit ein
bisschen temperatur dann geht nämlich
schneller aufs bild
einfach immer mit der mail mit rein
ich habe jetzt den teig jetzt etwa acht
minuten lassen also so langsam gehen
auch kneten habe denn ansonsten würde
einfach nicht schön geschmeidig
jetzt nehme ich etwas öl auf die hände
und c den teig ab wobei da jetzt auch
nicht mehr klebt aber eigenschaft sehr
weicht das ist ein richtig schöner
reicher teig für öl ich diese
arbeitsplätze
das mädchen noch ein bisschen bieten und
neben den teil gibts drauf
am besten geht es nicht so einer
tankkarte und jetzt einfach den teig
schön so einer kugel zusammen formen
ich habe übrigens einen kleinen rest vom
mehl übrig also herr fleck 20 30 gramm
das habe ich nicht mehr gebraucht
deshalb wasser schon gut sein kommen da
zurück in die schule liebefeld auch noch
leicht und dreh einfach den teig da drin
so ein bisschen dass er von allen seiten
bedeckt ist und solange jetzt auf gehen
für eine stunde bis es sich auf jeden
fall mindestens verdoppelt hat und dann
nicht richtig schön locker und luftig
man können wir gleich die atmo teilchen
formen
ich mach das jetzt hier drin ohne röhre
element und ihr könnt es auch gern im
backofen nach dem warmen so etwa auf 30
grad einfach mit einem geschirrtuch
abdecken oder mit einer schalte folie
oder eben auch in der kenwood der
hefeteig ist es richtig schön
aufgegangen wenn man sieht grund jetzt
nehme ich mir hier in das silikon mathe
gibt ein bisschen drauf und nimmt sie
bitte auf die handlung bleibt dran
kleben und mit mit hilfe dieser teig
karte den teig raus
der schritt richtig schön locker so wie
wir ihn haben wollten und jetzt portion
ihre ich mir das und nehmen halt immer
so ungefähr 40 mal 50 gramm stückchen
brot durch zustimmen
okay das jetzt 60 wahrscheinlich und die
portion ihre ich mir jetzt kurz aber ihr
kennt mich ich muss das ganze nach
messen was habe ich das 60 leichter
neben mama 70
also ich hab jetzt 24 dieser teilchen
hätte ich ganz exakt gemessen wenn ca 25
und jetzt nehme ich mir immer so einen
teig stück und rolle dass länglich aus
so einer langen rolle und dann zwiebel
ich das so in sich dann wird das ganze
hier schön verschlossen
und kommt auf dem backblech was ich sage
es noch mal so eine rolle formen nicht
zu lang ist soll ihr nicht zu dünn
werden dann zwirbeln und dann drumrum
legen und das ende verschwindet dann
einfach drunter also man sieht den
übergang praktisch nicht
und da auch immer wieder fett nehmen
auch wenn es nicht klebt einfach damit
diese schöne struktur dann später besser
raus kommt
ich habe jetzt hier ganz genau drei
blech heraus bekommen und die müssen wir
jetzt noch mal gehen lassen damit die
axa brötchen auch richtig schön luftig
locker werden texte dafür mit etwas
frischhaltefolie ab und gibt sie dann in
den backofen da ich nämlich auch 40
jahre 30 40 grad vorgeheizt und dann las
ich sie noch mal eine halbe stunde auf
gehen und dann können wir sie bestreiten
und dann auch gleich backen die abmahn
brötchen sie nicht schön aufgegangen und
jetzt kann ich hier mein eigelb mit dem
zucker vermischen
ich hatte jetzt die folie drauf deswegen
sieht so ein bisschen flach gedrückt
wenn man die ein bisschen lockerer drauf
legt dann ging es auch schon hoch aber
ich hoffe dass jetzt offen hochgehen
der zucker sorgt jetzt dafür dass es an
der oberfläche gleich bisschen
karamellisiert jetzt streiche ich das
mit dem pinsel drauf ich mache jetzt
noch kurz einen schluck wasser mit rein
dann geht es nämlich besser einfach so
ein teelöffel
den ofen habe ich jetzt bereits
vorgeheizt auf 180 grad ober und
unterhitze
dann der schwarzkümmel treffer und
schwarzkümmel dürfte nicht verwechseln
mit kreuzkümmel kreuzkümmel hat ja so
ganz starken eigengeschmack
schwarzkümmel finde ich fast sogar schon
neutral wobei wenn man drauf bist hat
auch zwei eigene geschmack aber ebene zu
penetrant wie kreuzkümmel und ich finde
es passt hier sehr gut oder ihr nehmt
einfach ein bisschen zäh samt das passt
auch so und so werden die jetzt für
ungefähr 20 minuten gebacken bis sie
schön goldbraun sind und dann zeige ich
euch gleich das endergebnis
meine art vor brötchen sind jetzt
gebacken ich habe sie zum abkühlen so
ein bisschen unter dem tuch gegeben
da konnten sie noch schön ausdampfen zu
sehen sie jetzt aus sie sind auch
richtig schön luftig und locker und ich
habe sie jetzt etwa zehn minuten
abkühlen lassen und jetzt zeige ich euch
noch wie ich sie belege hier können sie
natürlich auch einfach so lassen und
jeder kann sie dann am tisch gelegen wie
er möchte oder man kann sie einfach so
abreisen
als normalerweise normalerweise heißt
dass ich das einfach aussieht dann auch
schön diese strukturen diese lockeren
und dann kann man das einfach mit etwas
essen und riechen tut es auch richtig
fit aber ich probiere und zwar belegt
ist es jetzt mit etwas tomaten guten
hier habe ich etwas weichkäse also eine
kuh milch käse und bistro cola gewaschen
und es kommt da jetzt alles schön rein
ich bestreite das nicht mit butter oder
frischkäse weil ich finde die sind so
schon fertig genug sagt jetzt mal und
das braucht man hier auch dank
die
rucola macht und mochte ich früher
übrigens nie
das war irgendwann so als mein papa
metern erzählt dass das total der
fettverbrennung gemacht dass plötzlich
jeder also meinen eltern die sammeln das
immer im garten die am ganz viel rucola
und ganz viel presse sondern wild kresse
total lecker aber am anfang ziemlich
gewöhnungsbedürftig und legen sie muss
auf den tisch wie so ein salat
also eigentlich wir uns gerade auf dem
tisch und wenn dann gäste da sind wollen
sie erst mal probieren aber wenn der
papa sag du hast alles fett verbrennen
angreifer alle zunächst immer ganz
schnell weg es macht total witzig ich
habe jetzt übrigens noch beschlossen auf
die sandwiches muss jetzt natürlich noch
bitte chili darauf nach wird dann immer
noch und so weit ich das jetzt servieren
die restlichen lasse ich jetzt unbelegt
die darf sich dann jeder selber so
belegen wir möchte ich es auch ganz
gerne mit schafskäse und nutella
also es wird die kombination total der
geiz nicht nur weil ich schwanger bin
sondern auch sonst immer total lecker
mit nutella ohne wissenschaft käse drauf
oder wie sieht da drauf also ich mag
sowieso die kombination salzig und süß
immer gerne
und ja ich finde sie sehen stahl ecke
aus ich hätte auch gleich in einen
freien beißen und wenn ihr das rezept
nachmachen wird dann geht einfach auf
meinen blog absatzminus blog.de dort
findet ihr noch mal die genaue menge
angaben
und ich würde mich freuen wenn es nach
macht und mir dann einfach ein foto
schickt bis zum nächsten mal